pourquoi bravo ça a été magnifique libre
c'est un magnifique exploit je pensais
pas voilà elle ne pensais pas réaliser
cette performance mais elle l'a fait à
82 ans jeannette augusto a établi le
record du monde féminin de leurs des
plus de 80 ans avec une distance
parcourue de 28 km 226 très contente et
pippa fatigué ça a été moins dure car à
lire cody dernier et voit la super super
son entraîneur de l'équipe cycliste de
vélizy jean michel richefort a guidé
jeannette sur la piste des indications
de temps et d encouragement pour donner
le rythme et atteindre l'objectif
oui j'ai douté au début parce que j'en
étais parti très vite donc bien au delà
du tableau de marche
elle tournait en moins de 30 secondes au
tour alors que nous avions fixé trente
deux secondes au tour
j'avais peur qu'après un quart d'heure
elle fléchissent et jeannette elle ne
s'est jamais désuni elle a toujours
rouler régulièrement
et puis elle n'a jamais fléchi surtout
pour la soutenir dans son épreuve les
supporters sont venus de loin notamment
de rois le village où réside jeannette
en franche-comté encourager notre star
royaux lot
et extraordinaire a franchement super
génial l'aï pas tellement étonné non
vraiment oui c'est bien pis pour le
public des accompagnateurs et tout c'est
formidable je m'attendais pas à 100
c'est une surprise pour jeannette les
records s'est terminée elle va pouvoir
retourner à roye en reine du cyclisme et
continuer le vélo avec passion